and now in global snack we head to the
island of príncipe to check out a local
delicacy príncipe is an island off the
west coast of africa close to the
equator it's the smaller of the two main
islands of the nation of South torme and
príncipe and it's home to about 8,000
people the main language is Portuguese
it's Monday morning and at bærum our
preparations are underway for lunch
Judit Alfonso known as Donna tete a is
cooking the speciality of the day
moqueca de PA fish - five kilos of fresh
fish have to be scaled gutted and cut
into pieces
Makiki is the main vegetable in the stew
it's also known as african eggplant
the other ingredients are onions
tomatoes and coriander and mussel leaves
those are the leaves of the baobab tree
Donna today says they add a lot of
flavor and they're said to be good for
the digestion
Donna tete a open bear amar 20 years ago
she started out cooking at home the
recipe also calls for red palm oil on
príncipe almost everything is cooked
with it mr Moira how do they taste sour
no no I add the fish later so it doesn't
get too soft we cooked the fish
separately and add it to the stool once
it's almost done the stew is eaten with
rice bear amar has become a very popular
lunch place the stews turned yellow
that's the palm oil each portion has 2
pieces of fish it's lunchtime and the
restaurant is filling up a portion of
fish to plus dessert cost the equivalent
of 3 euros 50
the manga was very tasty it's a
traditional dish and she makes it every
Monday after an exhausting weekend we
come every Monday still gives us renewed
energy it's famous right from absolutely
Donna to taste you is the best that's
why the moqueca always sells out but
Donna Teti also has a few snacks for the
children to eat as they head home from
school
[Music]